[Music]
so as you guys know that the uh the
Biden campaign has now joined truth
social is that uh Donald Trump's app
that's a very smart play what is truth
social again Trump's uh social media
that was their Twitter when when he got
banned off of Twitter oh he started his
own wow is Trump back actually get on
that he Trum still is on Twitter and has
still over like 70 something million
followers
on Truth social he has only like 6
million but he still basically only uses
truth social
exclusively I guess that's smart from a
marketing standpoint it is smart yeah to
get on there but is it now like every it
just reinforces hate like everyone's
just roasting the [__] out of him on
that thing am I um well if you believe
in that there's no such thing as bad
marketing then like in a sense no
because it's actually kind of getting a
lot of uh engagement if you should oh
people love engagement yeah so are they
trying to do brand deals and stuff yeah
that's Biden's trying to do brand deals
for
fundraising but no the the the very
first uh I don't know I don't post I
don't want to call it a tweet truth
first the first truth that they posted
was quote well let's see how this goes
converts welcome converts converts oh I
like that convert shoes welcome yeah the
campaign wrote in its first post on the
platform under the handle Biden
HQ campaign followed up with another
post that featured a video clip of
Florida Governor Ronda Ronda Sanz
criticizing Trump's record on the
national debt so it's like got to be
pretty engaging because I mean they're
clapping back I'm a fan of yeah that's
cool to get info on both sides and you
know rebuttal and stuff that's great and
people are going to be interested cuz
it's like relevant topics what about RFK
is he on
there can you check if he's on there
what about RFK can you see if he's on
there the master dude you're so good at
fighting these I'm sorry don't roll your
eyes at me dude it's just it's
conversation you're the delay of game
King dude did you guys see that recent
Biden uh announcement he did about the
whole like um the issues in the Middle
East right now what did Biden say I
didn't see all of it so I can't say
that's why I was asking you guys if you
saw it so you could tell me no man I'm
touching that uh Trump has directly
attacked RFK Junior on Truth social oh
really what are you saying saying so
much for RFK Jr being a
republican real quick slammed him that's
tight cuz didn't he just announce he's
going to run as an independent as
independent yeah he probably has to
though right yeah I mean he's not going
to get the Democratic there's no way
there's a cityis bypass primaries and
compete directly in the general election
which is kind of a smart move cuz I
think in history we've never had an
independent winner but also in history
we've never been this polarized so I
almost feel like because the left and
right have pushed this far there is a
big path in the middle so for him to
jump on that freeway it might actually
worked he's got to watch out for Ross
per you never had an independent one
time in all history once not even close
huh but we've also Ross pero is probably
one of the close to this polarizing
before oh yeah I just can only see Ross
Pro in The Simpsons episode where he
like gets mad he takes off his hat he
punches through
it that was Ross BR right I know no
making sh Bob Ross I
know I remember they used to just roast
that dude all the time
on but I didn't even get why I didn't
even know who he was when I was a kid I
was too little yeah Biden's campaign on
Truth social uh his following actually
has now surpassed Trump's campaign whoa
not necessarily Trump the individual but
his campaign maybe people are just like
curious cuz they're like what the enemy
is here it is it is pretty cool I mean
how often do you hear about something
happening on Truth social yeah that's
true at all like you don't really hear
about it unless you're into that right
yeah well cuz I feel like truth social
is just a trump supporters social net
like it's not really like the public
that's what I figured if he only has six
million followers yep there are six
million users yeah people are only cool
with him if you don't follow Donald
Trump on Truth social what are you doing
well here here it goes out we got real
numbers on this um Biden's account Biden
Harris HQ has about 25,100 followers as
of Wednesday and Trump's team uh Trump's
team Trump had about
21,500 and quote the US president
presidential campaign is playing out in
real time on Truth social end quote
truth social said in an email announcing
Biden's campaign um don't miss the
action and since creating his account
dude those numbers are a lot lower than
I thought is it I mean it's not Twitter
it's it's but in general like these guys
got like 70 million votes or like plus
right so to for only 20,000 people to
follow and that's kind of weird that's
not the individual though that's just
their campaign oh their campaign yeah
yeah yeah is it and it just opened up
yeah it just opened up but I mean Trump
has team Trump on there with only 21,500
even though Trump has more follow on his
platform kind of kind of low numbers low
right Biden's team has used it to
criticize Trump's presidency and share
political news including about the
Israel Hamas war and vacant house
speakership so I mean they're they're
using the platform and saying what they
got to say in their campaign I guess
that's probably the most entertaining
thing to happen on there so you'd
probably want to keep track of it what
if you go on true social and just post
like not stuff that's not political you
think people do that like I wonder if
there influence yeah yeah hey guys
social Donald Trump style recipes that
you might like you
know re there's got to be like
Republican influencers on there or like
extreme Democrats that are like
Republican maybe yeah who's get is it
because people all got banned off of
Twitter I I haven't even opened it
actually so I wouldn't even know dude
there's too many social media [__]
platforms are we also like never going
to call it X is that like the thing well
it's because everybody who calls it X
even in article yeah it's always like
Prince right it's like X formally known
as Twitter because of like Yeah x is
just also a code name for ecstasy yeah
I've been going back on X these days
because it's you like it yeah it's fun
depending on the category of Interest
like it is a dope place to be but when I
go through it I'm like dude if I SP time
on this it's [__] over I thought you
were just saying what drugs you were
going back I was like congrats no you
know what it reminds me of going back on
X it reminds me of early YouTube when it
wasn't so easily like things weren't
like taken down so quickly so like when
there's fight videos like shooting
videos just like the craziest [__] it's
on Twitter it's on Twitter that's true
Sor Twitter technically was when they
started Banning certain things and
limiting free speech and whatnot and
because Elon took it over he was able to
put Trump technically back in play on on
any tweeted like once or something right
like I'm back yeah but also not really
that that X because it's like migrating
and moving towards like that more
broader platform that's supposed to
interconnect everything like you can
post videos that are like almost
unlimited length you can post like
different versions of post Now versus
like a 140 character tweet you know
crazy which is why shit's starting to
get more like whoa what is this yeah I
know a lot of people post like butthole
pictures on on X you're really into the
butthole thing all that stuff cuz I type
it in in my
search yeah well I know everyone does
their only fans on there right they
promote that there's a lot of like I
only go in there like when I was trying
to find and watch the Dylan danis Logan
Paul fight I'll go on X and be like
what's the clips you know like watching
clips from the fight but then even then
you don't it R is like that too really
like clicked on a thread and then cuz
you know now they try to promote it by
showing like like you'll be scrolling on
Instagram and then it'll show like what
people uh wrote on threads and you're
like oh what's that and then you click
and then the responses is just [__]
porn Bots like and then it's just ass
and [__] and whatever because like you
can preview a the thumbnail of the link
and that's the hack they put the link up
of whatever they're trying to get you
like you know and I'm clicking on it
putting in my info every time like
where's the pic dude linking my PayPal
just to see I never opened up a threat
weird but I never opened up I'm not I'm
not on thread I mean I I made an account
when everybody was making accounts but
then I've never used itly dead hey
whatever happened to Tumblr is that
still around no really Tumblr it's not
even used at all tum was tight when it
was when it was that's what Biden got to
put up everyone left because it it got
censored there just nobody uses it
nobody uses it it's like dead it got
censored yeah really by all the Tumblr
Enthusiast communities left because it
started censoring their [__] what do
they send what do you mean like what
like furry stuff used to be cool like
you could do whatever you wanted so you
could post like naked photos and stuff
it's probably just mostly naked stuff
for sure a lot of Kinks I mean a lot of
yeah it wasn't
just talking about FES I only just go on
Instagram there's too many social medias
for me to keep track of you don't even
go on YouTube not really he goes to 40
birthdays a
year he's too
busy all those kindergarten birthdays
yeah dude those are big truth tube huh
truth tube is that Rumble pretty much
yeah so Rumble is like the right one
yeah kind of yeah pretty much oh wait
not even kind that's right recipes dude
yeah there's Rumble make a rumble
account yeah we are why wait wait is
that the streaming one or the man I
sound like a [__] booms of sh what
com about what's the new one what's
parlor yeah parlor is a betting site
yeah yeah that's the Drake one no we was
talking about this the other day
remember what's the what's the streaming
one that all the all the people are
going on right now that's the kick the
streaming yeah that's kick yeah we're
we're supposed to we're supposed to
apparently go on that because we might
be kind of good on social media but
we're I guess we're just stuck to the
Boomer [__] [__] D I don't want to go in
there have a guaranteed contract with
the other people that go in there well I
think we got to on there in order to
create a guaranteed contract no no no
that's not how the other people went
there you from something yeah those guys
I'm like that's the cool deals well hey
PSA somebody poach us yeah reach out to
us you got to look real desperate play
hard to again yeah we don't even we go
where you we don't care I want to see
Biden live stream that be pretty tight
yeah do you think he could how long do
you think he can live stream
for if he falls asleep maybe like 8
hours just sleeping streams
[Music]
h